[Music]
holster started exploring views about
lgbt individuals and attitudes toward
gay rights about 50 years ago
a lot has changed since then since 1977
support for legal gay relations has
nearly doubled
support for gay marriage has increased
six-fold since 1988.
in 1977 56 of gay people should have
equal job opportunities
in 2019 93 believe this
26 in 1978 said that they would vote for
a qualified gay candidate for president
in 2019 76 said they would
why has public opinion changed more
people know
someone who is openly gay than did 50
years ago and familiarity
has met far greater acceptance also more
people believe that being gay is innate
and they don't want to discriminate
against someone whose orientation can't
be changed
young people led the change in attitudes
and today they are the most
accepting group of gay rights as new
generations with more liberal attitudes
replace older ones
acceptance will likely grow
is the united states ready to elect a
gay president let us know what you think
in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei